time is almost up for boris johnson's
premiership but is he leaving behind a
dark secret at the heart of his
government
a sky news investigation spanning months
looking into westminster culture can
reveal allegations of sexual misconduct
that go right to the top against a
serving cabinet minister and a senior
number 10 aide
to protect the alleged victims we've
allowed them to speak anonymously so
these aren't them you will see all their
voices but these are their stories in
their words i was sexually assaulted by
someone who's now a cabinet minister i
was in my early twenties and
didn't really know how to deal with it i
was super drunk he's feeding me more
wine and i'm already quite obviously
tanked but after a while i was like you
know what would you mind if i just went
to bed so i went to bed but obviously he
didn't leave me alone i woke up the next
morning and i realized what had happened
i reported it to an mp i worked for a
couple of years later
and i did go to the police years later
as well
and had a very brief chat with them
and decided not to proceed with a formal
complaint
because they couldn't give me any
reassurances until i made a formal
statement
i was too scared to kick start that
process and risk it spiraling out of
control
the second allegation concerns number
ten at the time the alleged victim had a
senior role in downing street the man
she accuses was attached to a political
campaign
i was working a conservative event at an
evening reception i was with a number of
colleagues in this room it was pretty
like crowded sweaty
full of men and basically i felt someone
grab my ass and i turned around and this
guy was just like looking right at me
she complained and then when she heard
he was about to get a top job in number
10 she raised it again
nothing happened i think my mind was
really opened basically about how far
people will go to protect people and
keep things quiet and basically just
brush everything under the carpet
when his boss a close aide to boris
johnson was made aware of the allegation
she claims he dismissed it others have
confirmed this i was told that the guy
who hired him said oh he's a
good-looking man he wouldn't do that he
has women throwing themselves at him he
said that to a few people
in relation to the first allegation a
government spokesperson said we take
allegations of misconduct extremely
seriously and there are robust
procedures in place to raise concerns
all ministerial appointments also follow
established processes
in relation to the second allegation a
government spokesperson said all
prospective government employees are
subject to necessary checks and vetting
we do not comment on individuals
a conservative spokesperson said there
is an established code of conduct and
complaints procedure where people can
report complaints in confidence we take
any complaint seriously
these allegations emerged during a
long-running sky news investigation we
spoke to people who work in westminster
at all levels from all political parties
and heard numerous accounts of sexual
misconduct and bullying there was a fear
among some that speaking out could end
their career others told us that these
stories circulate as gossip and rumor
but often no action is taken
what we found was that despite many
attempts over the years to change it
there is still a toxic culture here that
goes to the very highest levels of
british politics
are you doing anything to deal with your
party's toxic culture prime minister
boris johnson's premiership was marred
by a series of sexual misconduct
scandals including the one that
eventually brought him down the
resignation of his deputy chief whip
chris pincher amid allegations of
groping two men at a conservative
private members club mr pinscher what
exactly happened in the carton club
but it wasn't just the allegations it
was the question of who knew what and
when
and now that more have surfaced what
does this say about the prime minister's
time in office do you have any um
regrets at all over how you've dealt
with the um sexual allegations of
misconduct look i think all those
they're very they have all those things
have to be handled uh carefully and
sensibly and we have uh processes
for dealing with them
a shadow hangs over westminster but
change is coming it will be for the next
prime minister to say how they will get
culture here under control for good liz
bates sky news